[Musique]
moi qui nous échappe
à jouer
[Musique]
voilà je veux comme ça
ok
et le truc quoi ça nous rattrape le boss
droite peillon
c'est pas encore gagné ce qu'ils ont
sous le capot
monde lorsqu'elle est en vente
mais attendez pas à fond là mais des
comptes a envie de prendre une balle ou
quoi bah non c'est exact c'est la déco
nous ont tiré dessus at on peur qu'ils
nous tirent dessus à fond direct comment
on fait si j'ai déjà affronté nous
rattrape
tu as pensé à ça monsieur je sais tout
mais c'est pas comme ça que ça marche si
tu vas à fond on s'aime les mecs on
rentre chez nous soient sains et saufs
c'est pas plus compliqué même si on va à
fond et nous rattrape tu sais très bien
sûr une mauvaise foi chypre mule pas du
tout apprécié au japon attend la tête
toujours pas à fond non mais pas à fond
alors qu'il ne tient même pas dessus oui
ok ce que je sais c'est qu'en troisième
en nickel y est je crois qu'on les
aspects opposition de toi mec
et merde des autres c'est ça ouais
qu'est ce que tu avais dit ce qui est là
qui va la tirer
heureusement qu'ils savent pas tirer
parce que dans les selles désolé
heureusement qu'il fait encore une mode
turbo ya un mode turbo
évidemment qu'est mode turbo [ __ ] mais
là alors géré un jeu plus arty futur
turbo bleus turbo rouge tubes aux
enchères bien mais le buzz email
là on les rate mais ne trouvent toujours
pas soir des plus syntaxe et leur
affront direct aux mots parce que c'est
bon tu réalises que tu es en train de
vider m'en fous pas mais ça va je
t'avais de l'hôpital hôpital en gps vous
le tuez moi je mets la piquette un pic
un mot téléportation dans la bagnole oh
[ __ ] style et j'ai pas trop le magal
médias
je ne savais pas je te dis mais bien sûr
c'est la caisse de mon oncle tas
d'autres sérieux va dire cette fois
c'est bon tu m'a saoulé je savais même
pas que ça existait corruption savais
toi t'es quoi t'es quoi on n'est pas
obligé de tout faire ensemble non plus
je n'aime pas cette option sur ma
recette chimique au foot à idées pour la
caisse et tu vas téléporter ailleurs
toujours dans un autre pays d'évran
bourgogne ok manga l'année à plus tard
tu te fous de ma gueule tu peux voyager
autant avec évidemment mais beaucoup ne
l'a pas dit plus tôt je sais pas tu m'a
pas demandé à montebourg on à l'hôpital
mec si je pose ma main je l'attendais
pas que guérir et aux toits vous savez
le besoin d'être monsieur non merci
c'est bon ça va j'ai pu voir ça va
toujours y aller